-Hey, guys, it's time
for "Tonight Show Hashtags."
Here we go.
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
-Now, we do this thing every
week where I send out a hashtag,
and we ask you guys to
respond to that topic.
Since a lot of people will be
going home for Thanksgiving,
I sent out the hashtag
#MyFamilyIsWeird.
Within minutes,
it was a trending topic.
There's a lot of
weird families out there.
So thank you for playing along
and sharing your
weird-family stories.
Now I'd like to share some of
my favorite responses
from you guys.
This first one is from
@ReneeJordan78.
She says...
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's weird.
-Yeah, that is weird.
-That's perfectly weird.
-Yeah.
-I love it.
This one's from etes 97.
She says...
[ Cymbal crash ]
"I got it. I got it."
This one's from @Bonniezilla.
She says...
-Oh, that's not weird.
-That's not weird. It's love.
-It's love, true love.
-That's love.
-Save some money.
-Oh, this is good and weird.
This is from @SandraKLynn.
She says...
♪♪
"Now, kids, listen up."
Teach the kids
how to do it, yeah.
-Yeah, teach
the tiny children.
-Yeah.
-"In case you ever get
pulled over."
-This one's from
@QueenMomofSpart.
She says...
No.
-Not till they come out, yeah.
-They don't come out true?
-Yeah, no.
[ Laughter ]
-Sometimes, they don't come out.
-No, they don't come at all.
-This one's from @PDB435.
He says...
♪ Rock the boat ♪
♪ Don't rock the boat, baby ♪
♪ Don't tip the boat over ♪
♪ Rock the boat ♪
♪ Don't rock the boat ♪
♪♪
This one's from @kansasbradbury.
He says...
-♪ Car like our car ♪
♪ Don't rock the boat, baby ♪
♪ Car like our car ♪
-♪ Don't tip the car over ♪
-♪ Car like our car ♪
♪ Car like our car ♪
-This one's from JeremyDaly82.
Wonder if he's
related to Carson.
-Might be.
-He says, "My dad kicks off
Thanksgiving by using
a slingshot to launch
a turkey leg across the --"
[ Laughter ]
Hey, come on.
Don't judge him yet.
-Yeah.
-Hold on a second.
-Hold on.
-It might not be
as weird as you think.
-Okay. Takes a slingshot to
shoot a Turkey leg.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's fantastic.
-All year.
-That's fantastic.
-Judge him now.
-This last one's from
@kyledice23.
He says...
Those were our
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out more of
our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.